[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم انا بستانف
النهارده
حواري مع الدبلوماسي المصري البرموق
السفير رفعت الانصاري الخبير والمتخصص في
الشان الاسرائيلي وتحديدا الشان
الاستخباراتي والامني احنا تحدثنا في
الحلقه السابقه عن كيف تمكنت ايران من
انشاء برنامجها النووي الكبير جدا في غفله
من
اجازه المخابرات الاسرائيليه واجهزه
المخابرات الامريكيه والنهارده بنتكلم عن
بنستانف الحديث عن سبب هذا الفشل الذريع
والاستراتيجيات اللي اتبعاها الامريكان
والاسرائيليين
مش اجهاض بقى البرنامج اما وقدم ولكن
لتعطيل قدره الايرانيين على الوصول الى
القنبله النوويه مساء الخير معلش السفير
مساء الخير اهلا يا فندم هو انا بدات
بافتراض انه الاسرائيليين من جانب
والامريكان من جانب
فضلا عن تعاونهما قد فشل في منع ايران من
الوصول الى العتبه النوويه هل افتراضي
سليم
الى حد ما بمعنى ان احنا في الحلقه اللي
فاتت قلت لك انه في 2005 تمارس 2005 اتخذ
القرار
سياسي
بالاستعداد لضربه وكانت لسه ساعتها
اسرائيل كانت حصلت على ثلاث غواصات من
اربعه اسمهم دولفين
والدولفين الالماني دهوت غواصه لها قدرات
عاليه جدا بما في ذلك وضعوا عليها صواريخ
جيركو اريحتان اللي كانوا عاوزين يدوها
لايران بس كانت متطوره اكثر
هذه الغواصات
حطوا عليها
السيستم او المنظومه اللي اسمها برومس
ومنظومه ديت الاسرائيليين سرقوها من
الامريكان في التسعينيات والامريكان ما
كانوش يعرفوا
وطوروها وعملوها
بقت البروميس الاسرائيلي وكانت بتتباع في
الخارج باعتبار انها الامريكان وحققت
اسرائيل منها
ودي حلقات تانيه يعني ازاي اسرائيل تجسست
وسرقت من امريكا
منظومه منظومه منظومه كمبيوتر ومنظومه
تجسس
فكان عليها هذه المنظومه
وطلب منهم وراحوا الثلاث غواصات وقبعوا في
قاع الخليج العربي
ولمده ثمانيه اشهر في انتظار القرار
السياسي بالضرب
القدرات يعني اما جينا قلنا ان ايران
تعلمت الدرس من العراق في ذلك الوقت ايران
كان عندها ست مواقع فقط لغيت النهارده
ايران من سنتين تلاته كان عندها 17 موقع
وانا عامل خريطه بخط اليد بال17 موقع
بتوعها النهارده عندها 21 موقع
21 موقع دول اللي حصل ان هي قررت واوزعت
بمعنى انا عاوز مصنع ماء ثقيل اعمل اربع
مصانع ماء ثقيل وكلهم بقدرات متساويه
تقريبا بحيث لو واحد اتضرب ما تقفش الدنيا
والاربعه دول هوزعهم في شمال وشرق وجنوب
وغرب عاوز اعمل
مفاعلات نوويه واجهزه التخصيب هعمل اربع
مفاعلات وهوزعها عاوز المركز الابحاث هعمل
ثلاث مراكز ابحاث وحوزعها عاوز اعمل
المصنع اللي اللي بيصنع الهيكل بتاع
القنبله والمفجرات بتاعتها بعمل اربع خمس
مصانع واوزعها اذا وخلي بالك ايران كبيره
اما جمل الاسرائيليين يفكروا ان كان في ست
مواقع المواقع دهيت الضربه بتاعتها سنه
2005 الضربه بتاعتها كانت ستؤدي الى
اشتعال المنطقه بالكامل
وفي نفس الوقت هو قادر على انه يضرب ربما
ثلاث مواقع فقط من السته فهل ده كان هينهي
البرنامج لا كان هيؤدي الى تعطيله لمده
سنتين ثلاثه هنا تدخل مساد وقال انا قادر
ان انا اعمل منظومه واستراتيجيه ابتديت
فيها من 2002 فهذه المنظومه او
الاستراتيجيه لها
ثمانيه اضلاع وانا بدات احقق بعض النجاحات
فادوني فرصه علشان اكمل
هنا تم اتخاذ القرار السياسي مره اخرى بعد
ما وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه قالت الموساد
له حق ولابد ان احنا نتانى وفي نفس الوقت
هم ما كانوش ضامنين الحقيقه انه الامريكان
بسبب انشغالهم كما تفضلت حضرتك في الوضع
في العراق ما كانوش متاكدين ان الامريكان
سيدعموهم عسكريا ومخابرتان في مثل هذه
الضربه وربما لن يوافقوا عليها في البدايه
لما دخلنا بعد كده هنلاقي ان المسد ابتدا
من 2002 ما قيل ده كان اللي هو جه رئيس
استراتيجيه اسرائيل اللي هي من ثمانيه
بنود لتعطيل البرنامج النووي هل تاذلني
عشان ما اقطعش حضرتك وانت بتتكلم معنى كده
ان احنا نخلص من عاوز تقوله انه كان ادركت
بعد ما استفقت اسرائيل وعلمت انه ايران
عندها برنامج نووي سري وان هي فكرت في
ضربه واخذت قرار بضربه وهذا الضرب كان له
خطه استمرت قابله للتنفيذ لثمانيه شهور
وارسلت ثلاثه غواصات دولفين استوردتها من
المانيا ووضعت القوات الجويه على اهبه
الاستعداد وكونت في القوات الجويه اللواء
المتخصص المختص فقط بضرب المواقع
الايرانيه جيد جدا لكن ادركوا انه وقتها
كانت ايران حتى منشاتها الحيويه في سته
منشات رئيسيه كان القرار الاسرائيلي
بالتردد مبني على انه رغم ان هم ست مواقع
لكن موزعين في اماكن مختلفه ممكن ينجحوا
في ضرب بعض المواقع لن ينجحوا بسهوله
بعمليه او اثنين او ثلاثه في تصفيه
المنشات السته فضلا ان هذا يعني فرص نجاحه
ليست مئه في المئه وسوف يكون من
جانبه السلبي انه
ستشعل المنطقه في حرب هم لست ليسوا على
استعداد والجانب الامريكي الداعم الحليف
الرئيسي اللي هو الولايات المتحده لم تكن
ستوافق على مثل هذه الضرب وبالذات انه خلي
بالك انهم لما ضربوا المفاعل العراقي
ضربوه من وراء الامريكان
ما ضربوا المفاعل السوري ضربوه من وراء
الامريكان
فهم كانوا يتوقعوا ان زي ما عملوا بالنسبه
للمفاعل العراقي ان هم يعملوا ضربه
بتاعتهم بتاعه ايران في حفله من الزمن
ايضا انما زي ما قلنا كان اوردي المساد
مئر ده كان لما جاء رئيس المساد تم
اختياره كان كان هو الحقيقه احد القيادات
العسكريه اللي شارون بيثق فيها تماما
وشارون كان ساعتها في 2002 كان مسك بقى
رئيس وزاره وجابوا ومقير دجان اطلق عليه
جيمس بوند لانه ما قيل ده كان عقل مدبر فذ
الحقيقه
وعلى درايه كامله بالجوانب المخابراتيه
والعسكريه في نفس الوقت
وبدا يضع مفاهيم جديده داخل الموساد واما
قعد مع مستشاريه وضعوا
استراتيجيه وخطه من ثمانيه اضلاع ثمانيه
ابواب
نبتدي اقول لك مثلا ان الباب الاولاني
كانت ساعتها ابتدت الشركات الايرانيه يقع
عليها الحظر الاقتصادي
والحضره التكنولوجي وخلافه فكان هناك اللي
احنا قلنا نطلعه لهم شركات من بره ايرانيه
بدا تضييق الخناق عليها بدايه الخناقه على
الشركات الايرانيه اللي بدات تنتشر في دول
اوروبيه ومن خلالها تحصل على احتياجات
ايران لاستمرار في برنامجها النووي بالظبط
فابدا يعمل ايه بدا هو المساد يكون شركات
وهميه
هذه الشركات الوهميه تبدا في الاتصال
بمندوبي الشركات الايرانيه اللي هو عليهم
خناق وعليهم طوق امني مش عارفين يتصرفوا
ومش عارفين يتحركوا
ويقول له انا هعرف اجيب لك من الشركه
الفلانيه دهيت احنا شركه بريطانيه موجوده
في هولندا هعرف اجيب لك من المصانع
الهولنديه الجزء الخاص بالرقائق اللي انت
عايزها
يعني ابوس ايدك
كان
يعطيه قطع غيار معيوبه
والات ومهمات معيوبه
لما بيودوها لتبدا في العمل بيلاقوها انها
بايظه معيوبه ما يقدرش يرفع قضيه لان هو
واخدها اصلا من تحت الترابيزه بالظبط
فبدات هذه العمليه بداوا كمان
الاسرائيليين الحقيقه في
عمليات تخريب طائرات
من خلال عملائه اللي داخل اسرائيل ومن
خلال شبكاته داخل ايران اصلا ومن خلال
شبكاته المتواجده هناك بدا يرصد الطائرات
وغالبا كانوا بتبقى طائرات عسكريه هي اللي
بتنقل الكوادر العلميه العلماء والقيادات
العسكريه اللي بتعمل في البرنامج
وانا عندي قائمه يمكن بتناشر طياره تم
تخريبها
وتسع طيارات منهم وقعت وانتهى الامر يعني
يضرب الطيران اللي بيحمل العلماء
الايرانيين ما يضربوش يخربوا يبقى وهي
طالعه يحصل في حاجه اوريدي بتكون متخربه
من واحد من الفنيين بيعمل حاجه في المحرك
فالمحرك في اثناء الطيران يتوقف فالطياره
تقع
وكلها اسباب فنيه ولا يوجد صاروخ ضربها لا
مفيش يعني هي عمليه تخريب تخريب للطائرات
العسكريه التي تقل القيادات العلميه
عسكريه المتورطه في البرنامج النووي كاحد
اشكال تصفيه العقول الايرانيه مزبوط بداوا
في الحقيقه
الاقتراب من عدد من العلماء ومن القيادات
العسكريه اللي احنا قلنا عليها متورطه في
هذا البرنامج وبداوا يقنعوهم لانه العلماء
ابتدا يبقى عليهم حظر جامد الحقيقه
ويبتدوا مش عارفين يتنفسوا فابتدى يقترب
منه ويقول له تحب وانت طالع في اي حته
نعمل لك اجراء تهريب نهربك الى الغرب الى
الولايات المتحده حيث ستعيش رجل مكرم
وهيستفاد منه في مقابل ان انت هتديني كل
ما لديك عن البرنامج معلومات فعدد منهم
وافق ونجحوا بالفعل في تهريب عدد من
العلماء ومن القيادات الى الغرب والى
الولايات المتحده واجلم
ببلاء حسن بالنسبه للاسرائيليين فان هما
يا اسم يديهم معلومات
كان بيساعد الاسرائيليين الحقيقه فيما بعد
في خطوات اخرى
اجي بقى مثلا اما ابتدوا في ضرب المنشات
برضو الضرب المنشات وليست
الرابع يعني احنا قلنا في الاستراتيجيه
الاسرائيليه الشركات وهميه قلت عمليات
تخريب قلت مساعده في الهروب تخريب طائرات
ده تلاته قلت مساعده في الهروب ده الثلاثه
اربعه اما يجيئوا ينفذوا عمليات ضد
المنشات النوويه بص هتلاقي حرائق برضو ما
بيضربوش بصاروخ ما بيضربوش مش عارف ايه ده
قصه تانيه ايامها بتبتدي تشبت حريق يشب
حريق في
مبنى مجاور بتاع مصنع بتاع مش عارف ادوات
كوزماتيكس فيبقى في كميات في الحريق دوت
يروح ماسك في اللي جنبه ويكون مفاعل مثلا
يعني بداوا في هذه العمليات يخلي حد يخش
من العملاء بتوعه ويضع قنبله ده واحده
منهم وضعوا قنبله داخل
المنشات النوويه وتركوها لمده ثلاث سنين
ثم فجروها بريموت كنترول في توقيت هم
عاوزينه بدات هذه تخريب المنشات ومن هنا
ده يبتدي يورينا هناك اسلوب جديد لما
ضربوا في 2020 وضربونا تانز مره تانيه في
وضربوا شهر في 2019
مؤخرا اصفهان في تسعه وعشرين يناير بالضبط
يعني حصل القصه دي البند الخامس نبتدي في
اغتيال العلماء
بداوا الحقيقه من البدايه وانا عندي قائمه
طويله عريضه على الاقل مثلا من 18 عالم
كيف تم اغتيالهم في داخل ايران
وكان في البدايه ابتدوا بعمليات دس السم
والشوكولاته وهو قاعد في مطعم بياكل
جات له حاله واتنقل ومات في 24 ساعه ولسه
راجل صغير ثم انتقلوا الى عمليات التصفيه
تصفيه الجسديه من خلال
يبقى واقف بعربيته ماشي بعربيته يقف في
اشاره في موتوسيكل عليه اتنين واحد اللي
سايق التاني ورا ومعه مدفع رشاش بيروح
واقف ونطلع المدفع خلص عليه والموتوسيكل
طالع ولم يحدث ان هم مسكوا واحد من اللي
على موتوسيكلات دول على الرغم انها 12
قضيه اغتيال كيف يمكن ان نفسر تاني هم
ايرانيين عايشين جوه ايران كل حكايه انهم
فساد ايراني لكن هو ايراني وعايش جوه
ايران وفي نفس الوقت اصلا بمنتهى الصعوبه
يعني انه لو حد ضرب هنا وطلع جري
بالموتوسيكل ولسه مفيش بقى لحد بيجري وراه
ودخل بالمساك ونزلوا ومشيوا عادي دول
ايرانيين عاديين مواطنين ايرانيين فكان من
الصعوبه مكانهم ان هم يحصلوا عليها فضلت
هذه وبداوا الحقيقه ان هم مش بس القيادات
العلميه لا بداوا في قيادات عسكريه محسن
فخر محسن فخر زاده قضيه علميه تماما
لا هو مش عسكري وهو عالم انما لما حصل
القصه بتاعت انه
لما نتنياهو اعلن عن سرقه المستندات
ده اللي تمت سرقته في 2018
هذا الموضوع وقال كلمه واحده قال
والقائم على مشروع ده هو اسمه محسن فخري
زاده وافتكره كويس الاسم دهوت لانه انتم
هتفتكرونا انا بعديها باربع ايام طلعت في
برنامج قلت هذا العالم سيتم اغتياله
وتم اغتياله في نوفمبر نوفمبر من سنه 2020
انما الموضوع بقى بتاع فخر زاده كان اسلوب
جديد في الاغتيال
لا
بعربيه ولا بموتوسيكلات ولا مش عارفين هم
بداوا في يعني ملاحقته ورسموا مساراته
المختلفه بما فيها عربيته وهو مر امتى
بيبقى هو اللي سايق وامتى بيبقى معاه حرس
وامتى معهوش حرس
بالحرس بيبقى في عربيه وراه ولا بيبقى
راكب معاه وفين الاماكن اللي بيروح يمضي
فيها اجازاته لغايه ما اختاروا المكان
الصح وكان بيقضي فيه اجازه
وفي مسار العوده
عرفوا يختاروا حته بيبقى فيها
قرف كده حوادايا العربيه غصب عنها
وهو طالع كده كان في عربيه تانيه واقفه
وكان مثبت فيها
رشاش بعدسات بكاميرا
وهذا المدفع ريموت كنترول من عندهم في
المساد شوف جوه ايران على بعض ومعنى اصح
في مقوله اخرى ان كان هناك طياره قريبه من
الاجواء الايرانيه كانت بتطير وكانت عندها
القدره ان هي اللي تتحكم في هذا
والاهم بقى انه بعد وهو شايفه على
الكاميرا اللي هي موجوده في العربيه ساعه
ما شايفه هو جاي مجرد ما دخل واتضرب
المدفع الرشاش دوت هناك في تفجير ذاتي
فاللي حصل ان هو بعد ما ضربه ضرب 36 طلقه
فكانوا متاكدين انه مات المدفع انفجر
وبالتالي لم يكن هناك دليل يقدروا يمسكوا
يعرفوا ايه نوعيه المدفع الرشاش دوت ايه
نوعيه ان هو ازاي هو مربوط بريموت كنترول
ازاي هو بيتم التحكم فيه عن بعد ازاي
مزروع فيه
حكايه التفجير الذاتي والالي
اين توجد الكاميرا اللي كانت موجوده في
قلب العمله كل الادله دي تم تفجيرها بس
يعني هو في النهايه يعني البعض قال كده
يعني ايه كانه الصوره اسطوريه لقدرات
المخابرات الاسرائيليه فيما انه بعد كده
الايرانيين قالوا ان احنا عندنا مسؤول
وحكموا عليه بالاعدام وقالوا انه كان
متورط في تسريب معلومات عن تحركات العلماء
ومحسن فخر زاده يعني
اذا هناك اختراق واختراق امني خطير فازاي
يعني تقول انه دي مش عمليه خارقه لا دي
عمليه متميزه انما
يعني ما هي
قدرات ايران فانها كانت توقف حاجه زي كده
لم تستطع
وده بيجرنا الى سرقه المستندات
اللي تمت في 2018 يناير 2018
عاوز احكي لك قصتها يا ريت يا فندم
اقمار صناعيه بدات من افق واحد سنه 88
ومشيت اثنين وثلاثه اسماء الاقمار وافق
اللي هو افق بالعربي هي هي هورايزن بالظبط
فهو اخذ
القمرين الصناعيين سته وسبعه ودول اقمار
مخصصه للتجسس وحطتهم فوق ايران 24 ساعه في
ال 24 ساعه لانه كان عنده معلومات لكن مش
قادر يصل الى اين يوجد عرف ان هناك مركز
يوجد به الوثائق والمستندات الخاصه بمشروع
كان اسمه المشروع عماد والمشروع عماد توقف
في 2003 باعتراف الايرانيين في تعاملهم مع
الاتفاق خمسه زائد واحد وفي تعاملهم مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وما هو
مشروع المطبخ ما هو مشروع عماد مشروع عماد
كان سيؤدي الى انتاج خمسه قنابل كل قنبله
بقدرات ست اضعاف قنبله هيروشيما وهو عنده
البرنامج الصواريخ الباليستيه فكان اذا
انتج مثل هذه القنابل سيكون قادر على ضرب
تل ابيب القدس حيفا ديمونه صحراء النقب
منشات معينه في صحراء ادي الخمس اهداف
اللي كانوا موجودين عنده فاسرائيل كانت
مرعوبه من هذا المشروع ولكن طالما انه
قالوا لهم 2003 انتهى المشروع خلاص توقف
وهم قالوا ايوا متوقف المخابرات الامريكيه
كانت بتؤكد انه لا يوجد برنامج عسكري في
ايران بعد 2003 وهو ده من ضمن الحاجات
المستندات اللي هم قدموها ان هذا البرنامج
المشروع عماد توقف من 2003 وتم ديسمنتلينج
اللي هو ايه تفكيكه
يوجد يعني وثائق لهذا المشروع مش عارفين
يوصلوا لنا فابتدوا يبعتوا العملاء ابتدوا
يحاولوا يقتربوا يجيبوا معلومات وصلوا في
معلوماته بداوا الكلام دهوت في مارس 2016
وصلوا في ديسمبر 2017 الى معلومات كامله
متكامله عن الموقع وعلى فكره زي ما كان
عرضه نتنياهو لو هتشوفوا انه حاجه كده
مخزن بيت قديم شكله لكن ما حدش عارف انه
جوه فولتس خزائن على غرار خزائن
البنوك المركزيه وليست البنوك التجاريه
انما كونوا انه يصل الى جوه
رقم 12 ورقم 23
ويعرف يفك شفرات اولا عمل عمليه اقتحام زي
ما في
79 كان هناك المفاعل قلب المفاعل النووي
العراقي كان موجود في مدينه اسمها سرد
لمافت فرنساويه في الساحل الفرنساوي وكان
من المفترض انه هيتم شحنه الى بغداد عمل
عمليه ممثله لدي بالظبط دخل واخترق وعرف
ودخل على المخزن رقم مش عارف 28 اظن وهو
اللي كان فيه الكور وحط فيه القناه ومشي
ده بقى دخل وفتح الخزائن دهيت بشفراتها
وهم كانوا عندهم قدرات الحقيقه تكنولوجيه
عاليه قوي لكن لما فتح هذه الخزائن وجد
انه يوجد هناك 55 الف وثيقه و199
شخص مدمج بهما خمسين الف فايل ملف
وتم كان هناك شاحنتين موجودين تم نقل هذه
المواد كلها بالليل في الشاحنات وطلع
وقفلوا الباب زي ما كان زي ما بيقولوا
يعني
انا اذكر بقى ان انت الحلقه بتاعتك اللي
هي كانت بتاعه
واما هو بتقول هو قال انه اتصل بيك رئيس
المساعده وقال له انا مزنوق كانت العمليه
دي
كانت العمليه ديت لان هو كان عندهم البلان
ايه انه هيطلعوا ويختبئوا وجدوا في خلال
12 ساعه ان الدنيا مقلوبه عليهم
والايرانيين مصممين ان هم موجودين
وهيعرفوا يجيبوهم قبل ما يحصل اي حاجه اما
اتصل طلب مساعده السي اي ايه
لها قاعده اوريدي موجوده في اذربيجان
وتستطيع انها تساعد وبالفعل دخل عملائها
واتصل بالعملاء الامريكان الاسرائيليين
وعارفهم يهربوهم الى اذربيجان فعندما مرت
24 ساعه على سرقه المستندات كانت اوريدي
في اذربيجان وكان السي اي ايه محضر طائره
خاصه طلعوا عملاء المساد الى تل ابيب
بالوثائق بتاعتهم فكان هذا نوع جديد مبتكر
زي ما انت بتقول سرقه القرن لكن هذا نوع
جديد مبتكر من السرقه انا الحقيقهش بعمليه
القرن لانه اللي بصفه هم يعني
الاسرائيليين او لا الحقيقه الامريكان
والاوروبيين بيسموها انها سرقه غير معتاده
وغير عاديه في اسلوبها
وبتبتسم بجراه شديده
والحصول على معلومات دقيقه للغايه انما هم
استطاعوا ان هم يفكوا شفره الملفات
والوثائق ايضا لان الوثائق والملفات كانت
بشفرات
هو ده هم ما كانوش متوقعين ابدا انه هيتم
الاعلان عنها هم وجدوا ايه مش هو ده
الارشيف القديم اللي خلاص مشروع اللي توقف
هل هل المشروع شغال تحت اسم مختلف
ده الجديد اللي هم اكتشفوه وهم ما كانوش
قايلين على هذا
المشروعات مدين اي معلومات عنه المعلومات
التفصيليه عن هذا المشروع
اللي هو كان بيسعى الى برنامج ناوي عسكري
اللي بيصنع بيسعى الى برنامج ناوي عسكري
يتم من خلاله تصنيع خمس قنابل ذريه
توضع على صواريخ باليستيه ويتم بس انا
يعني اسمح لي ان انا اخد وجهه النظر
التانيه طبعا غير ان ايران ان هي بتنكر بس
الامريكان كانت تقديراتهم تقديرات
الامريكان لسنوات ليس لايران برنامج نووي
عسكري لانهم لم يعلموا ومن هنا يعني
السرقه ديت كانت السبب في ايه ان ترامب
بعدها مباشره خرج بره الاتفاق خمسه زائد
واحد طب انا عاوز اسال حضرتك سؤال لانه
القصه يطل شرحها وواضح ان حضرتك عندك
تفاصيل كثيره جدا لكن هو السؤال اللي
بيشغل الناس لانه اللي بيسمعنا بالمره لا
يعرف حضرتك قد يحصل على الانطباع او يحصل
انحراف بتقول ان الاسرائيلي ينظر عندهم
قدرات خارقه لا مش قدرات خارقه انا وانا
موجود هناك كانوا بيقولوا لي حاجه واحده
نحن لسنا مجتمع عبقري نحن مجتمع منظم
بنبني في عمل كل واحد مننا على السابق له
بالضبط دي كلمتهم فهم مجتمع منظم ملتزم
بيعرف يحصل على معلوماته بناء على تقدم
تكنولوجيا ما تنساش ان اسرائيل
هي حاله فريده من نوعها لان اسرائيل تتكون
من 85 جنسيه
اول ضرب والتصفيات والاختيالات
والطيارات
وتهريب العلماء على الرغم من كده
المشروع الايراني البرنامج النووي
الايراني ماشي خطوه خطوه وبالتدريج ووصل
الى درجه متقدمه تماما
ان ما يمرش في اخر ثلاث سنين ما بيمرش شهر
ونص شهرين غير ما بتلاقي ايران بتاع تلقي
القبض على شبكه تجسس تابعه للمساد من داخل
ايران اذا الجانب الايراني لازال يقظ ولا
زال مثابر وعنده جلد وعلى الرغم من
الضربات اللي بيتلقاها والخسائر اللي
بيشوفها الا ان هو مستمر ومستمر بشكل يعني
لابد انه بيثير اعجاب الغرب
والامريكان لانه كونه ان هو يصل الى
تكنولوجيا منتهى البساطه تكنولوجيا
طائره درونز اما تيجي تبص تلاقي ان 60% من
قطع غيارها هي حاجات لعب اطفال موجوده في
اوروبا وجايبه من اوروبا ان تلاقي ان
الموتور بتاعها موتور سكوتر مش حتى
موتوسيكل سكوتر هم اللي حاطينه فيها
اما يصل بهذه العقليه وبهذا الجلد في
المثابره في
عامله قلق في اوكرانيا وفي دول اخرى اذا
بيصل الى ان هو هو اللي بيصدر لروسيا
اندرونز ده معناه ان وصل الى درجه متقدمه
تماما وبالذات انه بيصنع درونز لها وظائف
مطلوبه على ساحات القتال بغض النظر عن
انها معقده
تكنولوجيا ولا لا
في درونز معينه اللي هي بتاعه الشاهد 136
وفي نوع منها اللي هو بيسموه الكاميكازي
اللي هو الانتحاري
اما الايرانيين يعملوا حاجه زي كده لا شك
ان الواحد ايضا يعجب بهم واللي بيعجب بهم
على فكره قبل الغرب اسرائيل
طب انا يعني انا كان في كل الاحوال كنت
حريص على اساس ان انا بس اطرح السؤال اللي
انا واثق انه يكون فيه اذهان الكثيرين لان
انا عارف من مناقشات السابقه لحضرتك انك
بتتكلم يعني بدون عواطف اذا وجدت وجدت
عمليه استخباراتيه كرجل لديك خبره طويله
عملتها دوله التشيك نيجيري اي دوله
اسرائيل ايران فانت بتتحدث بشكل موضوعي
فانا حبيت اوضح ان حضرتك لما بتقول ان دي
عمليات تفوق فيها الموساد في عمليات اخرى
ربما يتاح الوقت فيها كثيرا وعلى فكره
تاني علشان بس نعرف حاجه
العمليه يعني ما هو اصل الجاسوس ده له
حاجه من اثنين
يفشل يا بينجح والعمليه الجاسوسيه لو فشلت
بتطلع في الاعلام لو نجحت ما حدش بيعرف
عنها حاجه
هذه مشكله اذا العمليات اللي فشلت ولم
تستطع ايران اعلانها كثيره ولكنها ليس
موجوده في الاعلام فانا اسمح لي ان انا
قبل ما اختم ان انا اقول لن الخص لان
حضرتك قلت كلام خطير جدا في هذه الحلقه
الحاجه الاولانيه ان حضرتك قلت انه ملخص
ما قلناه في حوالي اربعين دقيقه انه
انه اسرائيل ادركت ان هناك برنامج نووي
عسكري لايران متقدم وسعت الى ضربه في 2005
ثم ادركت ان ضربه بعمليه عسكريه سوف يكون
له يعني عواقب اكثر بكثير من الفوائد
ولن يحصى بمباركه الامريكان اللي كانوا
غارقين في المستنقع العراقي وتقدرتهم انه
لا يوجد برنامج عسكري ايراني فضلا عن انه
المسته تقدم بخطه اما واننا عاجزين عن
ضربه لان ده كمان قد يفتح علينا ابواب
الجحيم وحرب في المنطقه كانت قائمه بالفعل
وبدات تنفيذها من 2002 والكلام ده احنا
كنا بنتكلم فيه في 2005 وقالوا ساعتها
احنا بدانا في عمليات ناجحه فلما لا نكمل
العمليات بديله عن ضرب عسكريه مباشره
عليهم اندلاع الحرب في
في يعني حرب غير مستعدين لها
وبالتالي بداوا وانتم حضرتك قلت ان هي
استراتيجيه مكونه من بنود اشرت حضرتك فيها
الى خمس او ست بنود على فكره البند السابع
كان عمليات تخريب سيبراني الكتروني اه ده
يستحق ان احنا نتوقف عنده يعني عاوز حلقه
لوحده والبند الخامس هو الدعم المعارضه
الايرانيه في الخارج داخل اللي هم النشطاء
النهارده اللي عاملين التظاهرات ده دعم
عظيم جدا وانه
الاستراتيجيه اللي هي مكونه من ثمانيه
نقاط اللي حضرتك اشرت اليها كان هدفها
تعطيل البرنامج اللي فشله في تصفيته
واخيرا حضرتك بتقول انه ودي معلومه مهمه
انه سرقه الارشيف الايراني اللي تم
بمساعده من الامريكي اللي تمكنوا من تهريب
العملاء الى اذربيجان بس في الخروج لكن
الخروج عمليه بالكامل كانت 100%
والامريكان ما كانوش عارفين حاجه مضبوط
مضبوط وده اللي بيقول كمان اللي كان رئيس
السي اي ايه وساعدوهم الى الهروب خارج الى
اذربيجان الى اذربيجانين طبعا هيزعلوا جدا
من حضرتك لانه في خلاف عنيف يعني مع
الايرانيين انما هي واضح ان قاعده متقدمه
للموساد الاسرائيلي الاذربيجان ما كانش
لهم يد ده محطتها في اذربيجان هي اللي
عملت العمليه الازهر بالجنين ما عرفوش
حاجه طيب ده اسوا بالنسبه
انما حضرتك قلت معلومه خطيره لانه بيمكنها
الايرانيين ان ما زال هناك برنامج عسكري
السري لم يتخلى عنه الايرانيون ودي قصه
استاذنك نتحدث عنها في حلقه لاحقه
خليني اقول لك بقى حاجه اخيره نختتم بها
في تقدير الشخصي ان الايرانيين لديهم
المعرفه والقدره والتكنولوجيه
والتكنولوجيا لتصنيع قنبله ولكن القرار
السياسي وهذا ذكاء من الجانب الايراني هو
بعدم التصنيع الان
اما ياخذ هذا القرار السياسي هيبقى عنده
من سنه ونص لسنتين اما تتصنع اول قنبله
وهنا
الاسرائيليين قالوا كلمه واحده بس
لا يمكن الخدوع مره ثانيه وده
النظريه بتاعه بيجن اللي قالها من سنه 77
فيما يتعلق بالمحرقه احنا لن نتعرض الى
محرقه مره اخرى بالنسبه لهم حصول اي دوله
عربيه على اي قدرات نوويه هذا بمثابه
محرقه اذن
النظريه بتقول لن اسمح لاي دوله عربيه
بالحصول على قدرات نوويه وكانت في الاول
كمان حتى ولو سلميه لان الاسرائيليين
نفسهم غيروا قدرتهم من سلميه الى الى
عسكريه في غفله من الزمن
ولا عسكريه وفي اللحظه اللي هيبقى فيها
اثبات دليل على ان هناك قدره عسكريه
بالفعل على تصنيع قنبله هتضرب زي ما ضربوا
العراق وزي ما ضربوا المفاعل السوري
والمفاعل العراقي سيدربه اي مفاعل موجود
بغض النظر عن الكوارث اللي هتحصل في
المنطقه هم هذا هو عقلهم وهذا هو منطقهم
وهذه هي يعني من خبرتي معهم هذا هو قرارهم
اللي موجود والايرانيين يعلموا ذلك تماما
فليس الوقت مناسب لتصنيع القنبله
والله حضرتك قلت لنا كلام بالغ الاهميه
ولكن ايضا طرح في ذهني واذهان من يتابعنا
الكثير من الاسئله استاذنك ان نرجعها
لحلقه مقبله نتحدث فيها عن مزيد من تفاصيل
الحرب الاستخباراتيه الشرسه جدا ما بين
الايرانيين والاسرائيليين انا جزيل الشكر
على السفير شكرا شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم
وهتابع تعليقاتكم واسئلتكم ومنها ان شاء
الله اذا سمح وقت ما على السفير نستانف في
حلقات اخرى الى